there's an investment scam I want to
talk to you about today which has
actually been around for a while but
it's really grown lately because of its
association with Donald Trump and this
is a general type of investment scam
called the foreign currency scam but the
one I'm going to talk about today in
particular centers around a practically
worthless currency the Iraqi currency
the Iraqi dinar the premise is this
right now
the Iraqi currency is really undervalued
so say the evangelists or some people
call them scammers so as a result it's a
really great investment opportunity if
you buy some of these Iraqi dinars now
with US dollars all you need to do is
wait until Iraq revalue the currency at
which point you'll make a huge profit by
exchanging the dinars back for US
dollars so to set up the math of it
right now one u.s. dollar is right
around 1200 Iraqi dinars or to say it a
different way one dinar is worth about
point zero zero zero eight four dollars
okay or point zero eight four cents per
dollar the people that are promoting
this scam claim that once the currency
revalue Zoar rvs as they call it one
dinar could be worth as much as three or
four US dollars or almost five thousand
times more valuable than it is right now
this seems like most currency investment
opportunities you buy now that currency
becomes more valuable you cash out and
it's a big win but the key here is that
there's something about the Iraqi dinar
that will in particular make it very
quickly increase in value so that in a
way that is connected with political
decisions or political circumstances and
we'll get to exactly what those are in a
second before this before the Trump era
the Denari ins have been saying that
this revaluation is just about to happen
it's gonna happen any day they've been
saying this for years at least since
2012 and if you check out the dinar guru
which is an online forum about the dinar
26% believe that this revaluation is
just days away
74% believe that quote the dinar will
not change until certain things are
accomplished and that will get us to why
this is growing so much right now if you
google Iraqi dinar the top results are
all forums that focus on this currency
scam like dinar guru the websites are
filled with all these little tidbits of
information about the political
situation the economic situation in Iraq
a lot of them are updated multiple times
per day the facts are very much
cherry-picked to make the readers feel
like this is on the verge of happening
this revaluation is is almost there it's
gonna happen any moment now and it's all
meant to get people to invest right away
without much research into this out of
fear of missing out on this great
revaluation and it also encourages
people who own dinars to keep holding
them this has been a known scam for a
while if you go back to 2013 the Better
Business Bureau specifically names the
Iraqi dinar as a currency that's often
sold in these foreign currency scams
along with the Vietnamese dong and the
Egyptian pound in October of 2018 the
Justice Department in Atlanta
successfully prosecuted the co-owners
and the chief operating officer of one
of the largest Iraqi dinar exchanges in
the United States convicting them a
fraud the business they ran was worth
over six hundred million dollars in 2015
federal attorneys for the Northern
District of Ohio tried and sentenced the
man to prison for running a fraud scheme
worth over 24 million dollars which
included selling Iraqi dinars
technically it's illegal to sell an
investment opportunity to the public
without a license but many of the dinars
sellers are operating because of a
technical a legal technicality we could
call it it's technically legal to sell
currencies if and only if they're
considered to be collector or novelty
items the other way that businesses are
able to legally operate is by
registering as money service businesses
MSBs
with the US Treasury Department this is
just one form you have to fill out very
little oversight as
actually happening the reason which we
are now getting to that this scam has
exploded recently is Donald Trump
because Trump was rumored to be an
investor in the iraqi dinar himself so
when Trump was elected in 2016 the scam
was revitalized with the idea that
Donald Trump's policy in order to enrich
himself which actually is not
far-fetched that he would do policy to
enrich himself would include the
revaluation of the dinar there's a 20-17
press conference where Trump actually
said that soon all currencies will be
quote on a level playing field a very
vague statement but when Trump said this
he was probably talking about Chinese
currency and the trade imbalance with
China but the Denari ins interpreted or
claimed to believe for the purposes of
pumping their scam that Trump was
talking about maybe revaluing the dinar
trumpets and Denari ins are two
different groups but there's overlap
between the two will summer has a great
article in The Daily Beast called Trump
fans sink savings into Iraqi dinar scam
which shows that many investors in the
scheme are also big Trump fans many of
them tweet about q and on one minute and
then about dinar revaluation the next to
understand why people could be led to
believe that this worthless currency is
actually on the cusp of an extreme
revaluation we've got to take a quick
look at the past few decades of Iraqi
history the current exchange rate as I
mentioned between the dollar and the
dinar is about one to twelve hundred
this means that if you went to Iraq
tomorrow and exchanged a hundred US
dollars for dinars you would get about a
hundred and twenty thousand dinar back
but the exchange rate wasn't always like
this if you go back to 1988 the exchange
rate was one dinar to three dollars and
22 cents meaning that a hundred US
dollars in Iraq in 1988 would be worth
31 dinars in return things changed when
Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait and by
late 1995 after that invasion and the
first Iraq war
the value of the dinar was down to one
dollar being worth roughly 3,000 dinar
things have gotten worse since the u.s.
invaded Iraq under false pretenses in
2003 and since then Iraq has been
continuously embroiled in insurgency and
civil strife which anyone who's been
following politics is aware of civil war
instability these are not good things
for a nation's economy and although
things have started to improve somewhat
recently in Iraq it's still precarious
Iraq is still engaged in the war against
Isis it's government is in a very
tenuous political position at best and
oftentimes people who are invested in
this scam like to bring up the example
of the Kuwaiti dinar which after the
Gulf War did actually experience a
pretty significant revaluation the
country is also Iraq's neighbor so it
might seem sort of superficially
reasonable but this is a misleading
comparison number one Kuwait's a much
wealthier country than iraq massive oil
reserves much bigger than Iraq's it also
has far fewer people to take care of 3
million in Kuwait vs. 33 million in Iraq
although Kuwait suffered damage to its
people and its infrastructure when
Saddam invaded that pales in comparison
to 15 years of constant war and constant
instability in Iraq much of it brought
by the United States with its invasion
in 2003 and even today Iraq still needs
to contend with the threat of civil war
which Kuwait did not have to deal with
the other important reality ignored by
the Denari ins is that such a
revaluation that they are saying could
happen any day would immediately be
harmful to the Iraqi economy and it
would only undermine the Iraqi
government's ability to pay its own
debts because an increase in the value
of its currency would make their
extensive government debt even more
expensive to repay and with the country
still requiring loans from the IMF and
other international financial bodies
just to maintain current spending levels
there's no incentive for the government
to push for that revaluation one reason
that the dinars scam feels real to many
people is that when you invest in it you
think you're getting something of real
tangible value a valuable asset on
YouTube right now there are an untold
number of videos of people excitedly
unboxing their shipments full of dinar
but the problem is that the dinar is not
even worth the paper it's printed on
outside of Iraq the only reason that
having dinar would be useful to any
American consumer would be if they were
traveling to Iraq not something that
many Americans are doing outside of
Iraq's borders there are no currency
exchange houses or banks that are
willing to exchange dinar for dollars
since no exchange exists dinar dealers
are able to charge whatever price they
want when you want to buy these dinars
or when you want to sell them the spread
between the buy and sell price is often
up to 20% which is outrageous compared
to any other stable or even remotely
stable currency so even if you say you
know what I'm going to cut my losses and
sell the dinar back immediately I made a
mistake you can lose up to 20% of your
investment instantly even without any
change in the currencies valuation these
denarian czar modern-day snake oil
salesmen but instead of curing physical
ailments this investment of only a few
thousand dollars is sold as potentially
curing all of your financial woes and
leaving you very rich of course it's not
going to happen and the Trump presidency
is only making the scam even more
prevalent